[Music]
on this Tuesday night the complex
process to free the two Michaels
what can the federal government do
diplomatically and legally our foreign
policy is being held hostage and what
legal experts say the Justice Minister
can do in the extradition proceeding
against among Wong Jo Ontario's first
child to die with Kovac 19 it's a
terrible thing and in the u.s. what dr.
Anthony Fauci fears is happening one
premiers pitch it's time to kick the
Serb to the curb the incentive to get
Manitobans back to work
plus the boxing gloves are off and the
medical gloves are on I wanted to help
and to make a difference
a Canadian boxer punches in at long-term
care homes
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the mounting pressure on
the federal government to take action in
the case of two Canadians detained in
China Michael Cobb Riggs wife says her
husband is in a fight for his life and
is a pawn in a geopolitical game in an
interview with the CBC she says the
Minister of Justice has the power to end
the extradition proceedings of Huawei
executive man Wong Zhuo arrested in
Vancouver at the request of American
authorities that could result in the
release of the to Michael's Calvary and
spa for China accuses Canada of being
America's accomplice and has demanded
hmong be released canada has
consistently said the extradition
process must proceed without political
interference our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson joins me Mercedes
this is tricky ground diplomatically
what are the legal experts telling you
Donna high-profile legal minds say under
the law Canada's Justice Minister David
linetti does have the power to freeman
Wang Cho and end her extradition process
right now if he wants to that's a very
different message than Canadians have
been hearing from the federal government
over the past 18 months Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau in the Liberal government
have said over and over they can't
intervene to end mung Wong Jo's
extradition we function on a rule of law
basis continue to defend the rule of law
we don't need to apologize or explain
for the decisions taken by our
independent justice system but one of
Canada's most prominent immigration
lawyers says that's not true
the legislation couldn't be clearer
section 23 3 of the extradition there
simply says that the Minister of Justice
may withdraw the authority to proceed at
any time
bryan greenspan penned that in a legal
opinion after being approached by
michael kava regs wife and former
Supreme Court justice Louise Arbour
as well as former liberal justice
minister Alan Rock all frustrated by the
government's claims that it's hands are
tied all we're saying is the right
exists the choice it says it's the
option exists Allen Rock says the
government was burned in the SNC lavell
on scandal
and now his
holding back from intervening in a case
where they have legitimate Authority our
two Canadian hostages are facing that
danger in China they're being subjected
to a show trial criminal charges were
laid last week in a court that has a 99%
conviction rate
Rock says it is in Canadian national
interests to intervene with lives of the
line and economic fallout hitting the
Canadian economy not to mention the
muting of Canada's criticism of China on
things like Hong Kong even freezing a
decision on how to proceed with 5g
technology our foreign policy is also
being held hostage and it's a load time
that that come to an end as well others
have criticized this approach as a
hostage exchange and fear that it would
send the wrong message to China
undermine a growing international
consensus that countries must stand up
to Beijing if we give in to this kind of
menacing blackmail and coercion then it
sets a precedent which could lead to
further incidents that would simply
embolden the Chinese government to do
more of this kind of thing in future so
Donna what is clear is that the minister
can intervene the question of whether or
not he should do so is much more
complicated
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
cases of kovat 19 are on the rise among
young people in many places where
restrictions are being lifted and now
Ontario is reporting its first death of
a child with Kovan 19 the exact age of
the child has not been released it was a
female under the age of 20 public health
officials say she had underlying health
conditions and tested positive for kovat
19 though that has not been declared as
the cause of death it's a terrible thing
to lose a child but in some cases not
saying specifically with respect to this
case but in some cases there are
situations where there are other
pre-existing conditions that it may
actually be the cause of the loss rather
than Kovac there are reports the EU is
preparing to block American citizens
from entering Europe because of that
country's failure to control the
outbreak of copán 19 according to draft
lists of acceptable travelers seen by
the
York Times Americans would be lumped in
with Russians and Brazilians as
unwelcome in Europe the US has almost
two and a half million cases and more
than a hundred and twenty thousand
people have died now a new surge in
cases has America's top health experts
deeply worried Jennifer Johnson reports
government doctors on the front line of
the kovat 19 pandemic told lawmakers a
surge in cases across America's Sun Belt
from Florida to Arizona has them greatly
concerned you are now seeing a
disturbing surge of infections that
looks like it's a combination but one of
the things is an increase in community
spread and that's something that I'm
really quite concerned about the number
of new cases broke records in over eight
states Monday two thousand in Arizona
three thousand in Florida masks are now
mandatory went out in public in Miami
some bars forced to shut down in Texas
Arizona is running out of hospital beds
and the upcoming flu season with kovat
19 still around has these experts
worried they're urging all Americans to
get a flu shot this single act will save
lives contradicting his staff I don't
u.s. President Donald Trump says he
wasn't joking at a Tulsa Oklahoma rally
when he said testing should be slowed
down these men say the president never
told them to reduce testing in fact
Trump's former testings are wants more
screening forty to fifty million tests a
month by fall especially now during
reopening when the need for testing is
the greatest
despite the virus surge in Arizona the
president visited the border wall in
Yuma turning his focus from the pandemic
to a key rallying point of the campaign
that got him elected
keeping immigrants out we have the best
security wall ever built and we'll have
it completed very soon the president
also has a campaign rally at a Phoenix
mega church physically distancing and
mask-wearing not required both of these
precautions are strongly encouraged by
this panel until there's a vaccine dr.
Fauci says large clinical trials will
begin in July and a vaccine could be
available by the end of this year or
early 2021
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
brazil's president has been ordered to
wear a face mask while in public after
repeatedly downplaying the risk of the
new corona virus Jair Bolton era has
been seen coughing while greeting crowds
the requirement to wear masks in Brazil
came into force on April 30th and today
a federal judge ordered volson ro to
abide by it if he doesn't the president
will face a daily fine of about five
hundred dollars British Prime Minister
Boris Johnson says what he calls the
long national hibernation in his country
is over and Brits can soon hit the pub
again bars restaurants hair salons and
most other businesses can reopen on July
4th the government is reducing the 2
meter physical distance rule to 1 meter
experts fear that will effectively end
physical distancing the infection rate
in the UK has been dropping and Johnson
says he doesn't believe the UK is at
risk of being hit hard by a second way
mourners gathered at an historic church
in Atlanta today for the private funeral
of Rashard Brooks a 27 year old black
man was shot twice in the back by a
white officer in a Wendy's parking lot
while he was running away he was
remembered today as a kind fun-loving
father of four they thought that we were
just upset for about 15 minutes but we
keep showing up we keep saying America
can be better than this and can I tell
you keep showing up keep marching keep
protesting keep raising your voice keep
raising the issue friends and family
wore black lives matter shirts and Phil
debe nezer Baptist Church a place where
Reverend Martin Luther King jr. once
preached Atlanta's police chief stepped
down less than 24 hours after Brooks was
killed and the officer who shot him has
been fired and charged with murder in
Quebec five retired Catholic priests
have been arrested at a retirement home
and they're facing sexual abuse charges
that date back decades the man aged
between 78 and 88 were arrested this
morning in the city of Joliet
north of Montreal
they face more than 30 charges including
gross indecency sexual assault and
molestation the abuse is alleged to have
happened while they were priests
teaching at a high school and to other
religious institutions between 1961 and
1989 police investigators say 15 men
have come forward saying they were
abused by the men and they were minors
at the time the possibilities with
pensions coming up why Alberta is
considering abandoning the Canada
Pension Plan
the Canada emergency response benefit or
Serb has been extended now until the end
of August and it's been a lifesaver for
many who lost their jobs but the
two-month extension will come at a steep
cost the Parliamentary Budget Office
estimates the additional eight weeks of
the serve will cost about eighteen
billion dollars add that to what's
already being spent since the benefit
was announced back in March and the tab
is predicted to top 71 billion dollars
more than eight million people have
received Serb payments Manitoba's
government wants people to get off the
Serb and get back to work
some critics of the federal program say
the $2,000 monthly payment is a
disincentive for people to return to
their jobs premier Brian Pallister is
offering to temporarily top-up their
income people who enroll in what's
called a Manitoba job restart program
will be eligible for an initial payment
of $500 plus three additional bi-weekly
payments of $500 each a total of $2,000
over six weeks
Global's Brittany Greenslade joins us
from Winnipeg with the details on why
the premier is offering to pay people to
return to work Donna Premier Brian
Pallister says this is a much needed
incentive to get Manitobans back to work
without a fear of missing out on
financial assistance
well the premier couldn't say how many
people in our province are currently on
serve or the student equivalent he did
say he's been hearing from businesses
who are unable to get employees back who
are collecting that $2,000 a month
benefit Pallister says his program is
meant to kick serve to the curb and kick
start the economy to some the Serb
programs become a barrier preventing
them from safely returning to work on a
more full-time basis and this is making
it more difficult here in Manitoba so
this program will make employers more
likely able to attract people to come
back and work because they can tell them
look you don't have to worry about
losing the $2,000 the provincial
government is going to give you that
money anyway now I spoke with one
business owner today who said he's had
employees refused to come back to work
and instead choose to stay on serve now
he would normally have third
eight employees at this time he's
currently at less than half of that and
they're doing what they can out of eight
interviews that they held they hired
four of those people only one showed up
on their first day of work the Canadian
Federation of Independent Business says
right now in Manitoba forty percent of
businesses are at their regular staffing
levels Donna alright Brittany Greenslade
in Winnipeg thanks Alberta is talking
about making a bold move and ditching
the Canada Pension Plan so it can be
replaced with one of its own a so-called
fair deal panel has studied the idea and
recommended an Alberta pension plan for
seed but this is not a new idea there's
lots of pushback to it and there's a
long road ahead before it happens Tom
Vernon joins me from Edmonton Tom let's
start with why why it's premier Jason
Kenney pushing the idea of an Alberta
pension plan Donna goes back to that
idea of a fair deal which is what the
panel was looking at look here in
Alberta they have long bean frustrations
with programs like equalization and
they've only intensified since the
economy dipped into recession here a few
years ago and Ballou deficits began to
balloon
now if premier Kenny says there is some
more leverage that can be found with
Ottawa here and an idea is to pull out
of the Canada Pension Plan and putting
Alberta's share of that money into a
fund it's estimated that would total
about 40 billion dollars which could
then be managed by the Alberta
Investment Management Corporation now
this is sparked heated debate between
kenny's UCP government and the Alberta
NDP is this premium really so intent on
settling the score with Ottawa that he's
willing to gamble the retirement plans
and future of millions of our burdens
why is the NDP so desperately against
having an in-depth study into the
prospective benefits of an Alberta
rather than Toronto run pension plan Tom
this isn't the first time this idea has
been studied what any experts who have
looked into this saying about it yeah
you're right Donna this was first
explored back in the early 2000s a lot
of work has been done on this now
premier Kenny says the idea behind this
is Alberta has a young population we pay
more into the system and we're getting
out right now so he believes that we
would actually be able to lower premiums
or get higher rates if we went the
Albert
one of the foremost experts on pension
management in the country wrote a paper
on this in January and he warned of the
risks the population is younger here
because of a large influx of people in
the oil and gas economy well that has
since shed thousands of jobs he says
Albertans need to be fully aware of both
the positives and the negatives of this
plan demographics change and you need to
think about these things before you make
any you know any kind of moves that seem
to favor you in the short term now Don
as you mentioned there's a long road
ahead here the finance department in
Alberta has been tasked look into this
idea and if it goes forward it would
have to be through a referendum also of
note an internal government document
shows that two-thirds of Canada's
provinces with two-thirds of the
population would also have to approve
the move Donna all right Tom Vernon in
Edmonton thank you still ahead a deadly
earthquake rattles Mexico's core
[Music]
people in Mexico City scrambled to the
streets after a 7.4 magnitude earthquake
shook buildings all over the capital at
least two people are known to have died
the quakes epicenter was more than 600
kilometres to the south in Oaxaca State
and it triggered a small tsunami the
Trump administration is considering
reimposing tariffs on Canadian aluminium
after accusations Canada is destroying
what remains of the u.s. aluminum
industry the American primary aluminum
Association claims there's been a surge
in imports of Canadian aluminum vital
for producing planes cars and other
products a year ago the Canadian
government fought to remove levies on
our metals but as Michael Couture
reports Canada has since lost some
leverage there have been surges on steel
and aluminum some some from Canada
substantially from Canada Canadians have
seen this movie before US lawmakers are
once again talking tariffs when it comes
to metals being imported from Canada the
decision to add a 10 percent levy could
reportedly come by the end of the week
if we in fact put the tariffs back on
with those they can't retaliate except
in in that sector so they can't
retaliate on agriculture and the like
and that's key because the last time
this happened in 2018 Canada was able to
slap reciprocal tariffs on 16 point six
billion dollars worth of American goods
including playing cards in Kentucky
bourbon Deputy Prime Minister Krishna
Freeland said in a statement they're
talking to their American partners about
this however the president of the
Treasury Board issued this warning
protectionism still exists and in fact
runs the risk of being even bigger and
being an even greater threat as we
emerge from the coal via health and
economic crisis the kovat 19 crisis is
the reason so much aluminum is on the
market right now because not a lot of
people were buying cars and
it's happened before it happened exactly
the same way back in the great financial
crisis of 2008 and 9 and it lasted for
certain period of time as the man
recovered it was a shift back to
value-added product Shah cmart also
warns making Canadian aluminium more
expensive could force American companies
to get materials from Russia or the
middle-east and it just adds to our
already frigid friendship with the US
you know it's on top of the border
closure which puts a strain on the
relationship there there are a lot of a
lot of strains here and and this
certainly isn't helpful and it's yet
another fire the Liberal government will
now have to put out my click root or
global news Ottawa next the Canadian
boxer who stopped fighting in the ring
to start fighting the pandemic
the FBI now says no charges will be laid
after what was thought to be a noose was
found in the garage of black NASCAR
driver Bubba Wallace investigators
conclude a garage door pull rope
fashioned like a noose had been
positioned there since as early as last
fall months before Wallace was assigned
to the stole that's novak djokovic
partying days before it was confirmed
the world's number one tennis player
this tested positive for covin 19th
Djokovic was criticized for hosting a
competition in Serbia and Croatia on the
weekend three other players have now
also tested positive
Canadian Kim Clavell has put her health
on the line in an effort to help the
vulnerable she was on the cusp of boxing
in her first main event when Kovac 19
hit as a trained nurse she decided to
take off the gloves put her dream on
hold and helped seniors living in
long-term care as Mike Armstrong
explains
she's emerged stronger than ever she was
just days away from the biggest fight of
her career in March when the pandemic
hit it was supposed to be Kim klevens
big break up that was my first main
event my first fight with my new
promoter so that was big now the
disappointment was strong but only for
about a day before boxing Clavell was a
nurse and with kovat 19 ripping through
seniors residences nurses were needed
desperately I wanted to help and to make
a difference so I sent my CV everywhere
Clavell jumped from residents to
residents over two months she lost track
of how many some shifts were like
nightmares caring for dozens of people
by herself as a nurse she'd worked in a
maternity ward this was very different I
saw a lot of people die each day one
person to person and that was I never
accepted that
the things calming down and Residences
Clavell is now quarantined with her
coach and training for a fight in July
but that breakout fight she missed that
was supposed to raise her profile isn't
going to be a problem this was a recent
surprise ESPN asked her grandmother to
tell her she had won its Pat Tillman
award for service
jemelle other bus Ibaka
there is no ceremony this year the
presentation was online over the weekend
Kim's story is inspiring and it's one a
service and great courage you're the
engine then make some things Lavelle's
break from boxing is now news from CNN
to People magazine she's probably got a
bigger profile than she could have ever
hoped for it's left her thankful but
also hungry to step back into the ring
she did do her best to stay in shape
during her supposed time off Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal and that
is global national for this Tuesday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
Cranbrook BC located just west of the
Kootenai River thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow take care
of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you